the government can't use the private  sector as a means to suppress your  rights but do I have a right to go into  the Apple headquarters I don't think  that's it if Tim Cook doesn't want you  to are you Tim you do have a right if if  uh building like the Apple Store well  she's the Apple headquarters if uh we'll  use the Apple Store as an example if  it's open to the public you do so like  any private company any little shop on  Main Street anything that anything  that's a public accommodation that  allows people to enter you can enter and  they can give you a warning to leave  then they can call the police the police  give you a warning then the police can  remove you or arrest you but if a  corporation is running a public-facing  publicly available business you have a  right to enter that business  they've already told you leave